hello guys and welcome to another
commentary video so the doctor strange 2
producer has teased some scarlet witch
unexpected scenes so wanda was last seen
in her own disney plus series 1 division
last year having finished the show in
the possession of some dark magic that
was surely turned ahead of doctor
strange both strange and wonder have
been prominent in the film's market and
thus far with wonder supposedly serving
as somewhat of an antagonist in the
upcoming film while the exact specifics
of a story in strange's adventure have
not been given recent quotes do hint at
what is in store for the two so doctor
strange in a multiverse of madness
co-producer richie palmer teased up
common things for wonder in the upcoming
sequel richie revealed her excitement
for scarlet witch's team off of doctor
strange saying fans have been eager to
see this for years and that they have
got to do this in a pretty fun unique
way that arguably two of the most if not
the most powerful beans in the mcu it
was only a matter of time before we got
them together and we do it in a pretty
fun unique way this isn't to say that
this will be a standard or
run-of-the-mill by any means as the
marvel producer mentions that despite
being a classic marvel team-up the two
do some things together that you'll
never expect them to do this would be
something different for wondering
obedient with strange as richie says
wonder has been through a lot but after
the ranch of one division she really
knows who she is this new feeling of
self-actualization will surely play into
the unexpected surprises richie is
teasing even the marketing for
multiverse of madness has taught fans
and they think it has been to expect the
unexpected when it comes to the upcoming
mcu sequel the film looks like it's
going to be a trippy cameo field
adventure through the multiverse so the
fact that fans are going to be surprised
by some situations one and trains find
themselves in is not at all surprising
but what could the specifics of those
unexpected shenanigans going to be could
wander become entangled with the marvel
illuminati that is rumored to appear in
the film or maybe she wants to meet her
animate the counterpart from the 1990s
x-men cartoon when dealing with the
multiverse the possibilities are
literally endless so one big note to
take from this is the word of um team up
because leading up to this film and from
the trailers that have been released it
has looks like our wonder was going to
be the antagonist of this film so what
i'm thinking is possibly she'll start
off as good and then she'll be combat or
she'll start off as bad and then turn
good or there'll be a variant of wonder
that we'll see in this film and she'll
be the villain but one thing to keep in
mind is at the end of one division in
the end credits scene of the last
episode she's looking away to find her
lost children through using the
multiverse which um would of course use
some dark magic so i feel like this will
be a big plot point for the upcoming
multiverse madness film anyway that's
about it for this video so do let me
know in the comment section below if you
think wonder is going to be a villain of
the film or not and also if you haven't
already please like and subscribe and
turn notifications on to show your
support thanks for watching